バンカラジオ1人のハンターの前に集め
られた7人の逃走者たち彼らはこれから
恐怖のオープニングゲームに挑む順番に
サイコロを振り目の数の合計が10を超え
た時点でゲームクリア逃走者には1分間の
猶予が与えられるたし目のマークが出た
時点で即ハンターが放出されるよし
[音楽]
行け
ゲームが始まっ
た僕たちが逃走中に出ると決まったのは
ある日のことだっ
た何して
たはいにお前らに嬉しいお知らせがある
ぞ逃走中大晦家小学生スペシャルの招待長
だ
すスお金もらったら何すんの俺は最近
お母さんにスイッチ壊されたからスイッチ
買えるお金があればいいかな米助君だっ
たら優勝できるよでも疲れるしな聞いたわ
俺は大晦か家で過ごすから出れないよ
えなんで出ろ
[音楽]
よこいつらを利用して俺が優勝して
やるハンターは司に捉えた逃走者を見失う
まで追跡
する早くこっちこっち早く来いあ急げ急げ
早く早く早く早く早く早く早く早く
[音楽]
早く子供をけとしての商品をいただきます
よこの男子供相手でも容赦はし
[拍手]
ないリと確保残る逃者は6名絶対あのじじ
のせいだろ舞台は巨大
迷路のような通路とゲームセンターが存在
するその面積はなんと東京ドーム0.7個
分このエリアを残る6人が逃げ回る賞金は
1秒200円ずつ上昇逃げきれば108万
獲得できるさらにこのゲームでは自主
つまりリタイヤが可能ただしエリアには1
体のハンター捕まれば即失格賞金はゼ
メルダ
スイッチが変える金額になったので僕は受
しようと思います最近の小学生は夢が
ない電話を奪い合う逃者
たみ何
してがあこでしょああもぱ先生が
最初え壊れ
た見つかっ
た
ちょっとなんだ
よ
くそ
ああメール
だ匠を確保残る逃走者は5名自首ができ
なきゃ最後まで逃げ切るしかないな残る
逃走者は5名果たしてこの中から逃げ
きれるものはいるのだろう
かあれなんであのお店だけ明かりついてん
だ
[音楽]
いらっしゃいませ今すぐ金を出せさもなく
ば誰か助け
て強盗被害にあったお店それを見ていた
ゲームマスターはミッションを
[音楽]
発動ミッションショッピングモール内で
強盗事件が発生した犯人は現金を持ち
ながら未だ逃走中だ逃走した強盗を確保し
現金をお店に返すことができれば30万
賞金が増えるただし確保に失敗した場合は
賞金が30万円減るこの30万はでかいぞ
俺はやる
ミッションなんてわけない
やろミッションに行くかどうかは逃走し
第見つけ
た強盗を確保するのは筋縄ではいかない
ようだに大丈夫かあの否をどうにかしない
と確保できないよどうするどうしようどう
しゆうとこじり
やけ犯人は普通に捕まえようとしても
厳しい俺ら3人で連携を取ろううん作戦は
こうだ
えたなくそうスロットに夢中の
犯強盗はエリア内を徘徊
するいた
うわ
ああええ女の子を傷つけるなんて最低
ええ
る
[音楽]
ね30万あれば何でも買えるん
やお前もる
なほら行くよ回しに行く
よ
っちゃ
どうぞありがとうございますっミッション
成功ゲームクリアの際に30万円プラスさ
れる一方その
頃くそ1ますちまっ
たミッション成功報酬に30万プラス
あっこしてるだけ
突然だけどみはこの間違い探し解けるか
[音楽]
な続きは書籍でバカラジオ超ハレベルで
やばすぎる間違い探し評発売中東京大阪で
本の渡会もやるわよ詳しくは概要欄
から残り時間60分ここで新たなハンター
が放出さ
れるうわあプリクラだプリクラに気を取ら
れる
こじりそこに忍び寄る一体の
ハンター見つかったどうしあちょっと待っ
てお願いがあるのカメラマンさん出てっ
てあの私のリコーダーあげるから今回は
見逃してもらえないえいいのありがてえ
みんなには内緒だよまた
[音楽]
ねあれパンタさん何してるんですかあ
ちょっと取り逃しちゃってえその
リコーダーもしかして買収されたんですか
おいやじゃあ貸せよ
それおおい
待て待ておい終ちゃったハンター
回代わりに新たなハンターが放出さ
れるおまおちゃん元気うん1人は危険だ
から先生についてきなさい分かっ
たちゃちゃん先生ついてたらだめだはめ
られちゃう
ぞ
け心配しないでついてきなさい
うん危な危ここは勝者が全ての世界逃走中
[拍手]
だドアが閉まり
ます困った時は先生を頼るんだよ
ありがとう
[音楽]
先生
1階
です上に参ります見つかっ
[音楽]
た先生騙した
なくそ絶対
男
[音楽]
メールだ魔を確保残る逃走者は4名この桃
があれば逃げきれるん
よそこにハンターの気配
が見つかった
やべえ足おそ
えい
おっとこんなんぐるぐる待ってたら一
つまんの
よエスカレーターを利用してデブハンター
を
煽る
おいうはもうのいて決まってるん
よ
ハンター
がちょちょちょちょちょずるいずるいずる
いってずるいってずるいってあ
あもう辛いん
よ桃のでかさと頭の良さは関係し
ないゆと確保残る逃走者はあと3
名
ユトも捕まったか残り時間は30分予算の
関係上絶対に逃走者を捕まえたい番組は
新たに3体のハンターを放出する私に
落とせない男の子はいない
からそこに忍び寄る一体の
ハンター見つかったちょっと待って
ちょっと待って待ってこれ私が使ってた
ラン
これあげるからゆいし
て女性に対しておけ作戦は無力
[音楽]
だこじりを確保残る逃走者2
名
おついに2人だけになったな先生も
なかなかしいですねお互い頑張ろう
な浜の目線の先にはハンターが
1人ほらやらす一緒に逃げるぞこっち
だほらこっちだに参りますドアが閉まり
ますえええああ
くっそああちくしまあいいどうせ俺の勝ち
[音楽]
だええええええ
あ
ちくしあみんな少子はどう
だ大子はみんなに確率にお金をあげられる
ようにしようと思ったんだけどダメだった
な先生よくも私たち騙した
[音楽]
なお前ら何だお走中ならぬ暴行中だ残り
時間10分ここで新たなハンターが放出さ
れる残る逃走者はやすただ1人
だおいカメラマンがあそこにいる
ぞということは助はそこにいる
ぞ
自主用電話で感電しているカメラマンこれ
は屋の仕業なのか残る逃走者である助は
カメラマンを巻いてどこかに逃げたよう
だゲーム終了まで残り1分未だにやすの姿
は確認されてい
ない
ゲーム終了まで残り30
秒カメラマンごと振り切った助は一体どこ
にいるの
[音楽]
か勝っ
たお前さの俺が逃者のやけだ
よこの番組めちゃくちゃすぎだ
なあのスーツ使えそうだ
なめ
[拍手]
よ
[音楽]
これで我はし
ないれてやんの俺が者のやけ
よ次は俺がゲームマスター
だ2023年ラジオを見ていただき
ありがとうございましたござ2023年は
留学に行ったり僕が休止して迷惑かけ
ちゃったり僕が東大便に落ちちゃったり
初めてテレビに出たり太ももが大きくなっ
たりはあ太もも見えるもももももも右から
左にもも令和のもも2024年もバンカ
ラジオは面白いコメディを作り続けます
それじゃ来年もよろしくねバイバイ
[拍手]
ょ
ちゃちゃちゃちゃチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録よろしく
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録よろしく最はチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録